Nick Saban Alabama head coach got Duke
coming up this weekend joining us
enroute to work good morning coach
thanks for joining us when when was the
last time somebody parked in your
parking spot I can't remember what would
happen if somebody parked in your
parking spot I mean just I don't know
that it would do any good but I'm just
is where it is us what if two apart in
your parking spot I probably have a
discussion with them you know sometimes
when key players on your team you know
do things even though you you really
have great relationship with them and
it's kind of not a big deal you know you
also have to realize that especially
when the key players do something
everybody else on the team is watching
you know how do you manage you know that
circumstance regardless of what it is is
really important to how they decide to
do things in the future you more patient
or less patient I think I'm much more
patient and then I would I've been
praying for patients for the last 40
years and I think someone answered my
prayers here in the last maybe 10 12
years that is I think it's it's made me
a little better you know in terms of
seeing things from a thousand feet
rather than just you know kind of being
anxious about getting it done right this
minute and sometimes it doesn't get on
the right way when you jump into things
that way without a good plan what's the
best piece of coaching advice your wife
ever gave you you know really probably
way back when when I was at Michigan
State um you know I was always so too
from the beginning of time when I was
became a head coach the media always
made me out to be sore the till of the
hon you know type of image and I was
always really really upset by that and
cuz I didn't think it was correct so I
said that to my wife once and she said
would you ever watch yourself in an
interview you're very anxious you're you
know not not very you know cordial to
the people you look nervous you look
like you're afraid you gonna say the
wrong thing it looks like you resent you
know the questions that they're asking
there so you know what why wouldn't you
why wouldn't they paint a picture of you
that's maybe not who you are
and I said okay and she said you know
sometimes a perception you have is
herself and the perception and everybody
else has is your blind spot and yours is
about as big as a Grand Canyon so that's
probably about the best advice you ever
gave me because I noticed that about
myself and tried to change but is it
your job to look like you're having fun
or sound like you're having fun you want
to ask you know if you are now sort of
joke around and not be too serious about
focusing on getting it right and doing
things right you know and you can laugh
and joke and practice and I'll be
serious not emphasized they'd like
disciplined execution attention to
detail and then you won't have any fun
at the end of the year you know because
the team won't really develop the
necessary habits that it takes to be
successful so it depends on what your
definition of fun is if it's joking
around and messing around and you know
throwing spitballs and meetings like we
did in the first grade to have fun then
you know I don't have much fun at the
end John Wooden talked about this in the
latter part of his career where the
expectation level was so
hi it was everybody expected him to win
a championship a national championship
at UCLA and it's it's the same with you
at Alabama can you is that is that fair
for us to expect Alabama to be playing
for a national championship well I guess
there's two ways to look at that I
really wouldn't
I really feel fortunate to have the
opportunity to be someplace as a coach
where they have high expectations and
standards for what they expect to
accomplish and what they expect to do so
that's you know the good news I think
the most important thing about that is
you you really can't focus on outcomes
you know when you're in a situation like
this really you really have to stay
focused on what do I have to do every
day to get the outcome that I want and
that's very challenging because we live
in an outcome oriented world but to get
the outcome that you want you know you
have to focus day in and day out what's
happening right now how can I get it
better what do I need to do to improve
you know you can focus on the score most
of the times when you focus on the score
and not the shot you don't get shot very
well so um that's kind of what we try to
do here and I'm glad that they have high
expectations
I don't think sometimes it's realistic
you know but at the same time we
understand that we want to get everybody
on our team to play the best and if we
have clear enough players and we're
fortunate enough to keep the right
players healthy um you know we'll have a
chance in the ANA to do something
special yeah I mean it's a compliment
that people think you're gonna be
playing for a national championship
every year I I'm curious what what do
you think is the first thing that goes
on a coach like what you know when
coaches decide that they're not going to
do it anymore
I think what's the one thing that leaves
you know I can't answer that because it
hadn't happened to me but
not not my hit left me I like then
didn't strike back that was actually a
motivation to keep going because I
didn't like sitting at home for the day
I said at home but I would say probably
so passion is probably a key word to be
successful at anything and if you don't
have that especially in sports I'm gonna
start to show in your work and we're
probably showing attitude of the people
who are looking least yet so that would
probably be a good answer to that
question
he said nick saban the Alabama head
coach he's got Duke coming up on
Saturday what if you found out that the
surgeon who was working on your hip in
the offseason was an Auburn grad there's
some things about people and there's
some things about school or all twos and
I try to keep those two do you have any
clothes that have like Clemson Orange or
or you know Auburn colors and like any
other colors and if I go into your
closet is it just all red crimson
absolutely not I have I have all
different kinds of colors but when I
choose the race or color time or sports
code or whatever there is an occasional
person that'll remind me that that's a
no-no that sent us an orange or whatever
so when you got the news about Dillon
Moses how do you handle something like
that when you lose a great player well
it's really disappointing it's
disappointing first of all for the poll
you know it's going to be a character
check for him to have to go what he has
to go through to come back to mr. season
he's a leader on the team I can cut in a
signal color on defenses and sometimes
very similar to be in the quarterback so
has a significant impact on you know a
lot of the other players on the team so
it becomes a
I character check for them to be
supportive to help the guys that are
taking their place to have the knowledge
help them get the knowledge and
experience so that they can go out
perform well and even though they don't
have the experience we can certainly
support them and help them as they get
the experience to develop and I think
you know that's not basically how we
have to handle as a team and I don't
think you replace guys like that because
they have so much knowledge and
experience and they're very very good
players and their leadership is
important to everybody else but you do
have to support the next guy every way
that you can know everybody on the team
has got you know sort of take it as a
character check and a challenge to do
their best to do their part maybe even
better than before so that we can still
be successful what did you make of Urban
Meyer send Trevor Lawrence is the best
quarterback he's seen a lot of attention
to what you know people say and I'm sure
that there's a lot of people that have
opinions about who the best is or make
comparisons but I don't really do that
you know we have a really really good
quarterback here and they have a really
really good quarterback you know they're
who you know you've recruited to come
here and thought was the best
quarterback let's come out of you know
high school you know one of the best and
so I think they're both really really
good players I don't feel it's necessary
for me to make a comparison the 22 best
quarterback you ever saw was who
Golic well you know this goes back but I
guess the best is always who is the guy
that made the greatest impact and
sometimes that happens early in your
career so when I was just starting out
in coaching maybe I was 27 28 years old
secondary coach
I stayed and we played against Stanford
John Elway was a cornerback and now he
was the first great quarterback maybe
that you know we played against and so I
think I always remember that one the
most
and I'm not saying that he was the best
ever under saying that because he was
the first that's the impression that
sort of does embedded in my mind that
that makes understand Jim I got Dan I've
had to play against him some more but
you know there was there was Molino and
you know Brady and a lot of other guys
that were really good players Joe
Montana and being on the defensive side
of the ball you know when you play
against those guys you can get really
frustrated calling the game because you
always feel like it one type of harm or
they always seemed so you're not pretty
quick and take advantage of whatever
you're doing coach always great to catch
up with you hope the hip is treating you
well and good luck against Duke this
weekend dan thanks buddy push it you
good way for more Dan Patrick show tune
in to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]